a lot of like lady friends read those
books and I didn't know that was a thing
me neither oh even younger girls be
white reading Danielle it's
it's steel man I didn't know
it was like a satire but they're in that
huh it gets pretty erotic oh you
read them have you read one I read it as
a kid his hair was as thick as Mane his
shirt was like flapping in the wind and
I remember being a little kid going whoa
what's my temperature rising oh whoa you
never hear other people using words like
that you know what I mean like I'm
reading like X-Men or like some Truck
magazine and it's very factual and then
we did the motor swap and now it's a
four by four
okay it wasn't regular English and then
you read that one you're like whoa whoa
swapping a mortar and suddenly it's a
four by four
something went wrong here